foreign
[Music]
that you want to pick up POI spinning
congratulations but where exactly do you
start what stuff do you want to pick up
at the beginning and in what order do
you want to pick those things up in
I got you covered Drex here from
drexfactor POI sharing with you the love
of poi spinning and flow Arts to benefit
your body and brain and today I am
counting down the 10 tricks that I think
everyone ought to start their flow
Journey with but before we dive in I
just want to give a quick shout out to
the Friends of the channel big thanks to
dark monk fire Mecca flow fests flow
toys juggling calling pyroterra light
toys spin balls and Ultra POI for
helping to make the videos on this
channel possible you can learn more
about all of these awesome companies and
the work that they're doing to support
flow artists like yourself by checking
out the links that I have down in the
description of this video and special
thanks to the non-business Friends of
the channel Lane machinsky and Becca
becklenen thank you both so much for
supporting my channel my work and my
mission
now I remember when I was first starting
off with POI the majority of my
education came from the tricks that my
local friends knew how to do plus which
whatever tutorials I could find on
YouTube now there's a lot more tutorials
out there including ones made by Yours
Truly but it's still kind of a mystery
as to what the progression should look
like there were a lot of tricks that I
picked up at the beginning that were
like really really hard and at the same
time a lot of stuff that I picked up
down the line that I wish I'd gotten to
earlier so I've gone ahead and I've
created a list of the 10 tricks that I
think are the best fit right at the
beginning of your POI Journey part of
this has to do with which tricks are the
most intuitive when you know little to
nothing about POI part of it is also
creating a progression and adding new
skills to the ones that you've already
Acquired and yes caveat this is a list
that is very specific to the style of
poi that I enjoy doing and I enjoy
watching there's going to be other
people out there that are going to have
their own list of 10 tricks that you
should start with that are going to be
different and you know what they can
make their own video but in in the
meantime if you're looking for a quick
guide for where to start and where to go
this should help you out and we're going
to get started with pendulums now I
truly believe that pendulums are the
single most intuitive POI trick that you
can start with partially because they
don't actually require you to be able to
spin the POI in any given plane and also
partially because they're a great
Gateway into learning timing and
Direction you can learn how to perform
these pendulums in together same
together opposites
split Time same direction and split time
opposites knowing those timing and
Direction modes is going to be a huge
help for you in everything that you
learn after this plus which pendulums
themselves make for a great transition
tool
once you've got pendulums under your
belt I truly think that the next logical
step are extensions now I've made pretty
clear over the years that I think that
we ought to think of poi as being
essentially an extension of the
performer's body and emotions and well
learning how to do extensions is a great
example of that to say nothing of the
fact that they'll totally use all that
knowledge on timing and direction that
you acquired with your pendulums plus
which the volume they take up makes them
super eye-catching and a pleasure to
watch
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
and of course once you have your
extensions down particularly those in
together opposites it's an easy road to
get to POI butterflies all you have to
do is work your way down from performing
together opposites extensions at full
arm then down to your elbows and then
just down to your hands and wrists the
butterfly is a classic trick and it
comes directly out of that work that you
do with the previous one
[Music]
next up the first POI trick that I ever
learned reels or real turns these are
essential for learning the basic
mechanics of plane facing that is
depending upon which side of the POI
plane you're standing on you may
perceive the POI to be moving in one of
two different directions reels are a
great way to practice this and begin to
gain freedom of movement by being able
to turn back and forth while you spin
your poi
[Music]
and rounding out our first five now that
we have several other POI tricks under
our belt an obvious question how do we
transition back and forth between them
well pendulums will work for a lot of
different things but if I'm going to be
real I'm way more fond of using stalls
whether they be down stalls bottom
stalls up stalls or top stalls stalls
are an incredible tool not just for
changing timing and direction or
switching back and forth between
different types of planes but also they
make for a great trick that can
punctuate the Beat of the Music that
you're performing to and they just look
cool as is
[Music]
next up given that we've already played
around a little with basic reels around
our hips our next move is to play around
with reels up near our shoulders and in
particular those in Split Time same
direction or as they're more commonly
known windmills windmills can be found
in two different forms either with our
hands staying up around our shoulders or
creating more Broad and open circles in
front of us before bringing our POI back
up and around our shoulders this ladder
variation is also really helpful for
what we'll cover next on the list too
foreign
[Music]
flowers now these are actually pretty
similar to the extensions that we were
playing around with earlier on the list
but what distinguishes the two is we're
taking a little bit more Act of a role
in determining what the relationship is
between how many beats we perform with
the POI and how many beats we complete
with our hands as they move around in a
circle
those windmills that we played with in
our last example actually technically
are flowers themselves but there are
many other examples and this is another
case where knowing all of your timing
and Direction modes is going to come in
real Handy
[Music]
and with both reels and in-spin flowers
in our wheelhouse it's not that far a
leap to get into What I Call Tuck turns
that is basically performing flowers
that wrap around your body these are
kind of the first step into the world of
body tracing and they look pretty cool
in and of themselves
and closing in on our final two tricks
on this list that's right it is the one
you've probably all been waiting for the
three beat weave this instantly
identifiable trick and probably the most
recognizable POI trick there is out
there has appeared in literally every
prop in human history that is remotely
close to POI it's also deceptively
difficult and takes a lot of time for
beginners to pick up that's why it's on
the tail end of this list but I also did
not want to forget it
[Music]
and before I share with you my final
pick for what POI tricks you ought to
learn first I have a favor to ask if
you've come this far and you enjoy this
video please consider subscribing to my
channel I upload regular videos on POI
spinning including tutorials reviews
flow sessions and a whole lot more so go
ahead and give me a subscribe and that
will lead us to my final pick it's waist
straps when you've learned how to
perform both the forwards as well as
reverse POI 3 beat weaves learning how
to turn back and forth between them is
absolutely essential to opening up
freedom of movement with those weaves
plus which it'll set you up for other
tricks down the road such as fountains
and body tracers and well it just looks
super cool this was one of my favorite
accomplishments in my first year of
spinning poi and to this day it is still
one of my favorites want tutorials on
some or all of these tricks hey I've got
you covered I've included a link to a
playlist full of video tutorials on all
these different tricks down in the
description of this video go check that
out and if you fancy this this idea of a
more structured learning environment and
getting to build piece by piece building
upon your previous knowledge I teach
beginner live stream POI dance classes
every Tuesday night specifically
centered around that premise you can
sign up for those classes over at
crowdcast.io
drexfactor POI what did you think of my
list were there any tricks that you were
expecting to be on here that weren't any
obvious ones that I missed which tricks
would have been on your list of the 10
POI tricks to start with let me know
down in the comments
thank you
[Music]
this video would not have been possible
without the kind support of all of these
lovely people right here these are my
flow patrons over on patreon they and
the people listed down in the
description helped to make this video
and all the videos on this channel
possible thank you one and all for your
very generous support and if you out
there watching right now are not
currently a supporter but would like to
become one you can do that by heading on
over to patreon.com
drexfactorpoi and signing up there you
can get access to a whole host of
awesome rewards and even better you'll
be supporting me in my mission to bring
POI spinning and flow Arts to the whole
wide world so go check that out please
and thank you and hey if you're super
excited to begin your flow journey and
just can't wait I'll include a link to a
playlist of my beginner tutorials down
in the description as well as up here on
screen if you're watching on YouTube
also the YouTube algorithm thinks that
you might like this top video here based
upon your past viewing habits so maybe
give that a look as well either which
way thank you so much for watching make
sure to get outside the flow today and
I'll see you with a new video on
Wednesday
peace